so die rasierklinge ist an ihrem platz
wissen creepy und wird erstmal ob das
ding hier auch wirklich genug hat kann
einpacken machen ist angeschrieben und
ich mache jede woche ein projekt in dem
wir uns irgendwas extrem cooles oder
irgendwas komplett dummes machen aber
wer kann jetzt schneller lernen oder
besser bauen um das herauszufinden
starten wir heute mit einem wettkampf
bestehend aus sieben folgen in denen wir
abwechselnd auf unseren kanälen
gegeneinander antreten in lernen und
bauprojekten derjenige der zuerst vier
folgen für sich entscheiden kann gewinn
staffel 1 und damit ruhm und ehre
los geht's mit folge eins kettenreaktion
ziel des wettkampfes ist es eine
kettenreaktion zu bauen jedoch
ausschließlich aus bereits in der
räumlichkeit vorhandenen strukturen
welcher banker und treppen sowie im
baumarkt erbärmlichen objekten für ein
gesamtbudget von maximal 50 euro
die bauphase in der sämtliche planung
und einkäufe stattfinden müssen beginnt
10 uhr und endet am selbigen tagen 18
stunden um punkt 20 uhr anschließend
wird wie immer per münze entschieden
welche der eigenen kontrahenten vor den
augen des jeweiligen gegners mit seiner
kettenreaktion startet und dann
umgekehrt gewinnen soll derjenige dessen
kettenreaktion ab dem zeitpunkt des
erstmaligen anstoßes am längsten aktiv
ist
dieses video wird unterstützt von blink
ist es ist punkt 10 uhr
letztlich habe auch gestartet was
jeweils zehn stunden zeit um die
fertigkeiten reaktion überhaupt zu bauen
oder zu müssen
vielleicht lassen wir es sein also was
ich mir überlegt habe was ich mir das
heimvorteil nutzen könnte sind
eigentlich diese balken sowas bestimmt
nicht wir kann man so sagen schön
irgendwie hinhängen ich will auf jeden
fall ein richtig schweres pendelt
einbauen sondern die ganze zeit hin und
her pendelt und dann irgendwas macht
wenn ich hier oben einen haken
rheinweiler könnte ich irgendwas von mir
nach hierüber schwingen lassen
ich find's gut dass ich das plant also
wenn ich jetzt sofort angefangen hat
sich halt nicht geschissen gekriegt hier
schläge verpasst perfekten
tischtennisball ein dass die wird meine
geheimwaffe erschien langlauf ist ganz
ganz ganz langsam weil die 644 euro nach
unten
dann ist da und er muss jetzt ein
bisschen weniger als sieben stunden zu
einer kernreaktion umgebaut werden dann
gucken ob es gibt 50 g fast ausgereizt
also ich hab ein bisschen geschätzt
ich wusste es jetzt nicht genau ist halt
auch prognosen aber metzger marius alter
update noch über sechs stunden zeit sind
und schon zwei mal rein
größe und position gebaut einer diese
rutsche wo quasi später
magath hier runter laufen soll weder
hier noch irgendwas anstoßen und die 250
gerade bahn bau ist dieser sei hier und
wer kann sie hoch stößt hier was an und
ist das rathaus jetzt bin ich ja auch
mal hier rein dass der plan wir jetzt
eigentlich dass ich das anschwingen und
dass das dann eine lange zeit hin und
herpendelt aber das wird super leider
gar nichts mache jetzt sollte aber
eigentlich gehen sie langsam auf dauer
das hätte jetzt einfach eine weile und
ja früher oder später wird es aus
pendeln ist eigentlich egal wie sehr sie
als kunden direkt gerät früher später
wird dann irgendwann bei diesem punkt
immer sein und man muss schon jetzt
werde ich nicht erst dann durch brennen
wenn es komplett still steht und dann
müssen davor muss man ja sagen kein
auffangbehälter bauen oder planen ja die
pappe und des maxxi besteht lage aber er
[Musik]
okay das ist mit 50 41 normale
tischtennisbälle sind nämlich zu leicht
um das auslösen deswegen habe ich
einfach ein mit wasser befüllt der
schwere jetzt schon zu geben dann ist er
zu lösen was sie wiederum das hieraus
müssen da jetzt hier weiter damit dass
alles funktioniert und ich will
eigentlich noch so eine kleine bahn baut
für titels werde habe ich es nur vier
stunden 20 ich habe viel zu lange
gebraucht bis das funktioniert jetzt
wollen nur noch so was wie ein scharnier
damit ich das ding hier auch widmen kann
aber wie kriegt das hin
ich könnte einfach verlassen weil es
gibt ja so oder so aber dann wird es
zeit den weg kommt dass man sich
irgendwie noch befestigen probiert jetzt
mal ganz billig ja wenn das funktioniert
dann khedira mich also das wird jetzt
das hierfür reichen dass es halt hier
nicht wegrutscht aber nicht dafür dass
es auch in der stabilen bahn bleibt ich
mache ich erstmal eine kleine box wo ich
hab vor die gute idee für ein genie als
erstes ist es jetzt schon so sicher
gelagert dass es halt nicht hin und her
rutschen kann großartig sondern einfach
so schön durch runterfällt und dann mach
ich jetzt hier können sie noch so ein
rad durch das ist ja auch nicht
unverhofft verläuft und dann läuft also
guck mal das ist doch jetzt eine nacht
lang mechanismus oder nicht bestimmt
kein verbot
ich muss noch hier was machen wir das
aufmerksam ich kann aber weiter machen
das ist halt nur so und so tief runter
fallen kann
das mache ich
frage wie man das verhindert so die
rasierklinge ist an ihrem platz bisschen
creepy und wird es erstmal ob das ding
hier auch wirklich genug zu hart was
kann einpacken
das war die perfekte länge
ich glaube sie nicht so höre auf und
selbst hat ja gar nicht getrübt
das wird versucht nochmal einzurechnen
jetzt schon scheiße und dann sollte das
passieren
in der theorie auf jeden fall ist
schlecht 300 stunden
ok also dieser mechanismus dass das ding
hier quasi nach oben schießt dann mit
diesen klingen hier einmal dieses seil
durchschneidet und der gummi dann auf
der seite quasi direkt und schießt und
dann später noch ein anderes macht aber
der mechanismus sollte jetzt in der
theorie vielleicht schon funktionieren
der provinz aber aus vorjahr okay nicht
ganz getroffen ja ein bisschen glück
wird schon treffen wir müssen glück dass
man sich eine rolle spielen
ich mache kurz den hier weiter
auszuholen der probier doch mal wo es
geht ja mal richtig cool wenn es trifft
also die idee wäre jetzt quasi die kälte
hier an zu machen und dann an dieses
seil
diese hatte da hier wenn du nichts
ausgependelt hat dann ist die pappe
lange genug hier beim feuer bilde dann
könnte die dann das hier an zone des
rieses schmilzt und runder fall und dann
geht die party los aber ich könnte mir
vorstellen dass die wahrscheinlichkeit
dass das dann nicht klappt weil es
irgendwie nicht richtig abbrennt viel zu
groß deswegen probiere jetzt verfolgen
dass ich drehe das ding jetzt mal auf so
und bis das jetzt ausgedreht es dauerte
eine weile und ich könnte hier quasi der
klinge ran
montieren und darauf hoffen dass diese
drehung dazu ausreicht das ding
durchzuschneiden würde gehen wer nicht
so cool wie das pendel aber ist ein
guter plan b noch anderthalb schon und
es funktioniert absolut gar nix das was
hier vor war habe ich verschoben da muss
ich noch ein anderes anfangen lassen
das ding steht nach wie vor funktioniert
auch wird später dann ist das gespannte
seil abschneiden wodurch dann dieses
gummiband genau diesen mechanismus quasi
auslöst das von hinten drückt diesen
draht dann quasi hier löst und hier
wieder nach andere coole sachen
passieren aber innerhalb schon wird das
was ich bin gespannt so jetzt gleich
eine halbe stunde
ich bin jetzt auch gefällt mir überhaupt
ich habe vorne noch ein kleines ziel mit
sushi fahren rhein gebaut und die vorne
los eine neue wippe
hier gibt es dann doch nur komplette
bahn und das schwöre ich so viel vor der
partie am anfang direkt also ich sag
wenn das rad kraft wenn es diesen
ratschlag und der ball angestoßen
wirtschaft zumindest bisher vorne
ob das klappt keine ahnung ich habe es
noch nie zusammen getestet ich habe
keine ahnung wie lange die zeit geht und
gespannt wie es bei thomas aussieht ich
kann mir gar nicht vorstellen dass er
gebaut hat check auf jeden fall den
ganzen teil gerade mal hat der ist auf
jeden fall das unsicherste an der ganzen
geschichte hier die letzte halbe stunde
angeschlagen es ist super es ist richtig
richtig knifflig und jede sekunde zählt
gerade einmal wirklich es komplett
unterschätzt wenn ich mal behaupten
damit ist das funktioniert okay der test
startet der zahn und es dreht sich und
es friedlich und das mit ewig dauern
aber dass die zahl 10 sekunden
[Musik]
hoffentlich geht alles gut ändern kann
ich jetzt eh nix mehr los geworden so
fertig also ich bin durch und markus ist
auf dem weg ich bin so fertig ist ja ich
hab ein tolles kopfschmerzen einfach ich
wirklich hab ich habe so gut wie gar
nicht gegessen ich habe nichts getan und
nichts ist so schön dass du gebaut hat
und wie lange gebraucht wir dachten
schon die ganze zeit wert ist
wer schon seit zwei stunden mittagspause
ich das war so klaus ich hab das nicht
nachgezählt ne ich war werde ich habe so
gezählt im rechner versucht 1 von 3
das geht ja gut wenn sie jetzt hier
scheitert dann wird er gar nicht
[Musik]
geklappt der nachteil da haben wir die
zeit geschafft
wir haben sie auf kamera auf jeden fall
[Applaus]
ja nicht fest auf dem boden ist ja wenn
es steht oder ja ich habe mich halt
darauf vorbereitet dass wir den
richtigen groove bringst du das
irgendwie pendelt hat sie sich
gegenseitig auslösen werde nur um
schwingen wollte
das sehe ich wieder da wieder als sie
alles aber ja okay ich werde ich mal was
schöne zeit ist okay ich würde jetzt
stockmann 58 ein halbwegs knapp 50
einhalb ich war also was wird wenn ganz
ganz knapp 3 2 achs bitte bitte bitte
dass die kritische stelle
es war das schwierig sei den ganzen
bruder war du mir jetzt ich weiß warum
das war nicht mehr gespannt
ich habe sie erst auf 632
ich hoffe warum machte diesen ich bin
ich würde versuchen es ist der letzte
versuch betreibt sein
das ist einfach nicht ihre strecke
dass gerade jetzt irgendwie versagten
griff und für thomas aber theoretisch so
weitergegangen
also was hier komplett schief gerade
keinen plan was da passiert ist voll das
funktioniert egal
theoretisch also hier dann da dran aber
es wird es langsam und dann fehlerlos
verstehe gras mit dem rasen gut so dann
hätte das gedacht
da das ziel geraden fährt immer noch
steht funktionieren müssten folgen
ich glaube das rad ein bisschen das ist
aber sechs folgen zum ausbau sondern von
aufholen der ausdruck ist noch dran
folge eins von sieben konnte ich also
schon mal für mich entscheiden weiter
geht's morgen mit folge 2 auf marius
kanal worauf ich beim einer
kettenreaktion besonders stolz war ist
die planung das buch checklist strategie
beschäftigt sich damit wie die
checkliste in allen bereichen unseres
lebens nutzen können um mehr zu schaffen
und weniger fehler zu machen
die linke ist gibt es den kerninhalt
tausende bücher zu den themen
wissenschaft produktivität
persönlichkeitsentwicklung und viele
mehr zusammengefasst auf dem circa 15
minuten und zwar zum lesen oder zu hören
jeden monat erwarten euch 40 neue titel
in 25 kategorien und auch klink ist
punkt.de story könnt ihr jetzt eine
woche lang ohne abo soviel lebens
verändern das wissen auch sagen wie ihr
könnt wenn ihr wollt erhaltet ihr dann
20 rabatt auf das jahres-abo blinkt es
premium erste link in der video
beschreibung linke.de storari schaut
morgen oder vielleicht bei euch schon
heute bei markus wieder vorbei in dem
sich zeigen wir doch marius aufholen
kann bei dice stacking der link dazu ist
auch in der video beschreibung und wenn
er mich jetzt auf dieser reise begleiten
möchte hat dann abonniert gerne diesen
kanal und dann sehen uns noch nichts von
mir macht's gut
[Musik]